the jurogan experience how long do you
think until trump comes on this podcast
he's not going to you're not going to
happen i don't think so i don't think so
and even a couple months maybe though
why
i you know he's he's going to try to run
again i think you think yeah i think
he's gonna do that patriot party thing
that's what i think
he's gonna do something he's gonna come
up with some name for it but patriot
party seems
right up his alley yeah like that seems
like the kind of party that a guy who
has a gold toilet
would come up with that's the name like
i would imagine he has a gold toilet he
calls it the patriot party
he's probably going to do a do his first
press conference on american flag tie
it's probably going to do well if he
does but i don't think it's going to do
as well as it did last time
it would have done much better if it
wasn't for the capitol hill attack
the capitol hill attack sunk his
battleship
i think that's a wrap yeah i think
that's a wrap for him
could in his aspirations then first of
all they're never going to let that die
they have this thing that he did that is
this real
it's a real thing he really did say we
need to show strength
march towards the capitol he really did
incite these people to do this
and a lot of the people that did do it
they're using him saying that
as their legal defense the people that
got arrested they said trump told us to
yeah it's [ __ ] bro and now he's immune
to all these lawsuits
i bet he's just gonna have piles of
lawsuits he's not immune to lawsuits
yeah yeah he's yeah he's well he's also
in trouble because
whatever lawsuits he like he could never
par he could have never pardoned himself
from the lawsuits from the state so the
state
like all the criminal charges the state
was filing against him
were always going to be possible and
new york state apparently is filing a
bunch of [ __ ] against him they're not
going to let him go ma'am
it's going to be rough right gonna be a
rough time probably jail time i imagine
he should have pardoned snowden he
should have pardoned snowden and should
have
pardoned julian assange they mean
they're coming after him anyway he
should have
at least he would have got the support
of a lot of people on the left
at least he would have got the support
of a lot of people that
that could have at least acknowledged
the positive things that he did like the
fact oh yeah the economy was kicking ass
before colvin oh yeah unemployment was
down oh yeah
deregulation does have some benefits but
yeah he did bad things and that but but
but this is you know this is real and
but no one's even going to talk about
those things now
like that's you you'll hear it from some
republicans that'll bring up
what about the good things that trump
did and they'll have like some fox news
segments
or they're disgusting and you know oan
that network and
newsmax they'll they'll [ __ ] try to
beat it down but at the end of the day
that capitol hill thing that's that's a
wrap i'm surprised you didn't do tiger
king man
like you know like that guy was trying
so hard
yeah he i think he said that trump said
that he thought trump
he thought that trump felt like he was
too gay to pardon
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify you can listen to
the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience